last time you came here on this program
and we were chatting you were here for
Sons of Anarchy and you brought the
whole cast with you which was really fun
and I didn't bring them you invited them
which I thought was an awfully bold move
yeah seven years of working with them I
know it's like wrangling a pack of wild
animals
yeah and that shot actually shows a
fight breaking out at one point you know
there's a when Andy's smiling in the
background you know I'm curious like
they look like I know there's a phrase
in the UK Ireland which is they take the
piss out of you if you are elevated in
some way they want to bring you down
what was it like being on the sons of
anarchy set when you find out that
you're gonna play the title role in the
new King Arthur movie what were they
like well it started off with a little
as you said taking the piss I showed up
and everyone was wearing Burger King
crowns a photo of that jokesters but
then all of that dissipated pretty
quickly because they realized that I was
now the king of England and the rest of
the characters had not been cast yet so
it was like oh do you think there might
be anything for me and then I said well
you know take the crown off maybe we'll
have a conversation suddenly you've got
all all of the power
you